Pour ne louper aucune vidéo,
abonnez-vous etactiver la petite cloche.
Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Aujourd'hui, nous allons
faire des pop corn.
On va s'éclater et eux aussi.
Un peu d'huile.
Des grains de maïs.
"Corn" en anglais.
Le préfixe "pop"
correspondant quant à lui
au bruit que génère la cuisson.
Comment passe-t-on de ce
grain parfaitement lisse et régulier
à cette forme chaotique et boursouflé ?
Et bien lors dela montée en température,
l'eau contenue dont le grain de maïs
se transforme en vapeur.
La pressionà l'intérieur du grain augmente.
La vapeur cherche à s'échapper.
Elle pousse sur la coque du grain qui
finit par céder.
C'est drôle j'ai l'impression de décrire
une éruption volcanique.
Une premièrefissure se dessine
et le maïs éclate.
La vapeur peut enfin se détendre et l'amidon
contenues dans le grain de maïs
prend du volume comme
un ballon de baudruche.
Et voilà du pop corn!
Deux chercheurs français ont étudié de très près
le phénomène en 2015
et ont apporté leur grain desel dans cette histoire.
Ils ont découvert trois choses.
d'abord ils ont remarqué que l'explosiondu maïs
se produit en général à une température d'environ 180 degrés
quelle que soit la taille
et la forme du grain,
ensuite ils ont identifié l'origine du "pop".
Caractéristiques au moment de
l'explosion du grain de maïs.
Quand la vapeur s'échappe de la coque une dépression
se forme àl'intérieur du grain.
C'est à ce moment précis que retentit le "pop".
Un peu comme lorsqu'on débouche
une bouteille de champagne.
C'est la dépression à l'intérieur de la bouteille
qui est à l'origine dubruit.
Enfin ils ont compris pourquoi le pop corn saute.
Au moment où la coque du grain se fissure, un morceau d'amidon
en forme de bras jaillit en se détendant comme un ressort
Ce qui fait bondirle pop corn.
Et voilà on obtient du maïs soufflé.
Pour terminer une petite pincée de sel
ou desucre.
De mon côté c'est plutôt sucre et vous ?
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo, n'hésitez pas à
laisser un pouce bleu.
Merci les Épicurieux !
Pour les plus gourmands, en voici l'autre et pour
ne rien rater abonnez-vous et activer la cloche.